to make an appearance on the screen I
work with them living technology and I'm
not an architect I was actually trained
as a medical doctor and I've made the
very logical decision that my field of
research is actually more appropriate in
the built environment than in medicine
and you'll start understanding why that
might be what I consider myself to be
doing is actually designing
environmental pharmaceuticals in other
words agents that can remediate chemical
imbalances in the environment as opposed
to the way we traditionally think about
them as being the exclusive realm of the
human body obviously if you don't have a
condition then you don't need the
medicines the same for the environment
as it is for the human body so according
to mr. blainville who usually is
trustworthy one can predict that in less
than a hundred years all Venice be
totally united with the rest of italy
and you can walk dry shod from Italy to
the city 1771 what we're really bad at
is predicting the future what we're
really good at is somehow surviving it
and when I say we I mean life as we know
it on earth scientists like Paul Davis
now think that life itself was
extinguished many many many times from
asteroids showers before it finally
established itself 4.5 billion years ago
and it's still going yet the environment
on earth is not kind any structure on
its surface that persists requires an
awful lot of energy to keep it in some
form of homeostasis after all in nature
even mountains a mood so what makes life
so resilient
well thats spurry there's a very good
question is very debatable I personally
think it's got something to do with
embodiment its robustness and
flexibility and what these managed to do
somehow is confer this system with the
ability to respond in real time to
environmental changes and therefore it
maintains its contingency in its
surroundings now obviously associated
with this strategy is a lot of drop off
so there are mass extinctions many
organisms die but actually that is part
of life strategy and it's a totally
different kind of strategy to other
persistent systems take for example the
city of Venice itself which is in
northern Italy situated on the shores of
a lagoon on the a Adriatic Sea and
Venice seems to stand seemingly in
defiance of all the elements and the
climate and the changing forces of
nature and it does so not way it's
living properties but by a lying itself
within it with technologies that are the
latest of the epoch in which the city
has a symbiotic relationship with humans
I do know that I'm personifying quite
dramatically here but this is in order
to make my point so the time that the
city-state of Venice was being founded
between the ninth of the 12th century
the dominant technologies were agrarian
in other words land drainage the
creation of canals and the use of wood
piles to shore up the foundations of the
developing settlement and these actually
form a really important feature of the
city today but with the industrial era
we have a new set of technologies ones
that bring great power and wealth
although through the excessive use of
energy in order to create a
down atomic scale control mechanism
through which matter is subordinated and
this comes at a huge environmental cost
here for example is marghera this is an
industrial park just north of the city
of Venice on the mainland this is where
I sometimes work in a laboratory
investigating the technologies of life
this laboratory in this rather
interesting tower it looks incredibly
industrial and is situated actually
between an oil refinery and a
shipbuilding yard that builds ocean
liners so leaving the laboratory in the
evening one is met by the rather surreal
spectacle of towers that are burning and
buildings that are peer to be moving and
because of the environmental impact of
the industrial era and its technologies
it is perhaps not surprising then that
environmentalists are objecting to an
industrial scale solution to the acqua
alta the high tides that are now be
setting the city of Venice so much more
frequently over the last century this is
some graffiti objecting to the
installation of the Moses project series
of 78 mechanical gates designed to stop
the tide rising and spilling over into
the city itself reminiscent perhaps the
Danish King Canute who dared the tide to
stop and stay away from his realm but
this is this is a serious problem the
tides like nature and the environment
are not benign walking along the canals
in Venice once these beautiful buildings
were really being digested away by the
elements you can start to see these
classic scars caused by environmental
impact and interestingly it's at the
shoreline that the greatest damage is
done it is
so much the wood piles that are
constantly submerged under the water
that are actually preserved by the say
line but those that become exposed by
the changing levels of the tide that are
a most damage here is the classic signs
of efflorescence the white dusting on
the brickwork which is the chemical
concentration of salt crystals that
literally act like the contents of our
stomach around a donut literally turning
it into its constituent molecules and
the city inhabitants are quite desperate
about doing something about the gradual
digestion of their city as you walk
around and put your hands in cannon ball
sized holes in the walls one can find
acts of death architectural desperation
like lumps of concrete rubbish rubble
sand chewing gum you so is it all over
the Venice should we believe the doom
mongers and the those people that just
to say that say that we should really
just vacate the city of Venice that its
survival is is is something that will be
consistent with the stories of the city
of Atlantis and other cities that have
been reclaimed by the sea I believe not
I believe there is hope and there's hope
in a very odd place in the east of the
city of Venice is a public gardens and
underneath a strange oak tree in those
Gardens is another canopy this oak tree
is no ordinary oak tree of course it
wouldn't be it's situated in the middle
of a building designed like a nautilus
which is a banded shelled mollusk that's
rather squid-like designed by the
architect and rico para su t and
underneath the natural canopy of the oak
tree that's in the middle of the twisty
building is another canopy an artificial
canopy and you can see the feathery
fronds of this can
II just underneath the oakleys foilage
let's go closer this this is hilar
zurich ground this is an installation a
club a collaborative architectural work
for architect Phillip Beasley
technologist Rob gore bay and myself and
essentially this is a cybernetic
installation modeling the earth the air
and life within it and Beasley's fund
like complex architectural forms respond
to changes in the air to the breath and
proximity of human inhabitants and
visitors and Rob's cybernetic system
manages the information gathered by
these sensors and by these mechanisms
that are relating to change within this
space and converting them then into
effectors into actions that are then
meaningful so in this particular
installation here we actually have front
like tongues that actually lift and lick
people as they approach you'll also see
various LEDs which communicate with each
other as people move through the gallery
space and in the center there you'll see
giant swallowing tubes which pulsate
through hydraulic mechanisms and all of
this is the integrated environment but
let's go closer into the foilage of this
artificial installation we start seeing
some chemistry's which I designed that
have living like properties this is one
of the kinds of fruits this is a self
evolving chemical and precipitation
diffusion reaction it means pretty
patterns that look like fractals and its
inner is this in an arrangement that
shows the change of these chemicals with
time but here's the one that I want you
to focus on and we'll go in and zoom in
a little
this this this golden all seems to
contain some chemistry's or some little
black opacities in the middle there
let's see what's in those and as you can
see from the side they're actually blobs
of chemistry's that are actually
interacting with each other and actually
it's a very very very very simple system
and yet it's incredibly complex what's
in it is extra virgin olive oil some
water and some inorganic salts let's go
further still why is that exciting well
there's that there's a picture of it
absorbing energy which facilitates the
chemistry with time and with passage of
the people to the space so the chemistry
and the cybernetic installation are all
connected and here we are going closest
still each of these has a personality
now what you'll see from this movie is
that when I haven't made them very very
still which is what I did for the
installation so they'll last for three
months is that this oil and water
droplet system despite not possessing
any DNA is incredibly dynamic in fact it
possesses properties that can only
really be described as a living these
droplets are able to move around their
environment sense it respond to the
presence of other protocells or these
little primitive cellular agents and
undergo complex reactions like the
shedding of skins or the creation of
shells as well as undergoing populations
scale cut and be kind of behaviors which
results in extremely complex phenomena
and I have movies of those but I'm not
going to show them to you so essentially
what you're witnessing here is the birth
literally quite physically this this
amniotic sack of a form of sort that's
been created by the interaction of the
surface of the oil droplet with the
watery surroundings and this droplet is
responding vigorously to its environment
by creating this this skin of crystals
very very soft crystals and it wriggles
its way out of its birth things that
and becomes free into the environment
now what's so exciting about this
particular kind of technology well I
believe that this is the very first
technology that is genuinely complex it
doesn't behave according to the control
systems that we would normally associate
with say for example industrial
technologies machines or digital
computers there's no on button there's
no off button and it's extremely
sensitive to its environment although
don't have the film here those agents
that have been created in similar
environments can detect the tiniest
disturbances say for example traces left
by its by their by their neighbors and
just like humans these protocells don't
like their own waste and they try and
move away from it so if another
protocell has crossed the path of one
protocell it actually goes you and it
turns a shot right hand corner and moves
away from the front from the waste
products so they really do have
incredible life like properties but not
only that mean that's just the hardware
I consider this oil and water droplet
system as being a form of programmable
hardware and why am I talking about
programming because if we actually use
the body of the oil droplet as a
container for the slow release of other
chemistry's we can now start to
distribute matter in time and space and
that starts to change the engagement of
the technology with the environment
entirely so what you're looking at is
another kind of fruit within this
cybernetic canopy and what you see is
that as a little green precipitate
around an agent that is actively
extracting carbon dioxide that's been
dissolved in the solution which has got
into it through the breath of visitors
that have inhabited the city we've all
been inhabited the installation space
and also we've actually used Venice
water in there so it's been dissolved
into the into the lagoon waters from
which we've drawn the source of water
and so gradually it's making this carbon
dioxide and visible and also
precipitating it out from from its
context so so okay so how can we use
this well I've created a set of am proud
of salt populations that can actually
use carbon dioxide and turn it into a
form of paint that can repair brick
fragments you can see these protocells
now moving around and some Venice brick
fragments and creating white scars of
brickwork not only to bridge the gap
between the damaged bricks but also to
create a protective layer around it so
now we're starting to grow a limestone
she'll let me quickly show you a
speculative proposition as to how we'd
use this in a full-scale Venice would
introduce protocells into the lagoon
waters which would be programmed to move
away from the light we know we can do
that we also know that they can deposit
substances like carbonates which
essentially is the same kind of stuff as
carbonate so then with time these
protocell populations make their way to
the darkened foundations where they're
energetically at a lower level and start
to precipitate their limestone neck
structures around the wood piles and
effectively this offloads the point
point load of the of the city so it's
currently standing on stilettos on soft
Delta soils if we spread that point load
over platforms which is what we're doing
here then we can effectively stop the
sinking of Venice or at least attenuated
in some way and of course the whole
issue of sustainability and environment
in in Venice is an incredibly complex
problem to solve but this is one
approach that may help attenuate some of
the kinds of stresses they're not just
Venice but other cities challenged by
changing water levels may face and this
is a future Venice scenario which kind
of looks like a Back to the Future a
retro future we can also program these
protocells to for example become a paint
to absorb carbon dioxide and other
pollutants around future cities and we
can also use them as the basis of the
next generation
solar cell that doesn't produce
electricity but biofuel and so
essentially because these are the
technologies of life life being
ubiquitous these technologies have an
application and a scope that won't
prioritize or at least won't marginalize
developing countries or countries have
their own oil and water and inorganic
salts available to them very very
locally and ideally the idea would be to
release an effective recipe using mobile
SMS messages and get people to encourage
encourage them to develop these
technologies within their own
environments in their own niche
applications and so essentially living
technology is important because going
back to the beginning the most effective
survival mechanism that we know when a
planet is life itself now what if our
cities could engage with those processes
as well as the industrial and the
digital and in greer ian processes and
technologies that we already know and so
living technology is unique in the sense
that it offers a way forward in this age
of environmental and architectural
uncertainty by not pretending to know
the future but by oba by being able to
respond in real time to immediate
changes in the environment and therefore
persist just like life itself does
good afternoon um I was asked to speak
today after a story I wrote in the
februari issue of Fast Company
investigated the notion of smarter
cities you can find this online I think
on the conference website and fast
company's website but you know the
notion of smarter cities has been around
for a very long time at least 20 years
when I believe it was a Xerox PARC
researcher named Mark Weiser came up
with the idea of ubiquitous computing
and in that vision sort of it was a
notion that instead of the old-school
vision we have of the matrix where you
project your consciousness into the
computer is william gibson and and Keanu
Reeves has us eventually we would be
embedding computers into the fabric of
everyday life and to our clothing and to
our buildings everything else and since
then the notion of smarter cities has
gone through various names various
iterations I think some of the most
latest of the notion of the Internet of
Things where everyday objects will have
sort of data attached to them and sort
of sensors and you can sort of trace
their lifespans or augmented reality
which in its current forms you sort of
walk around with your iPhone and you can
sort of see data projected onto the real
world these are all sort of early
versions of smarter cities that were
seeing and for a long time that sort of
notion of a smarter City languished it
was sort of seen as a sort of
retro-futuristic dead jet Sony envision
you know you know the type if you've
ever seen sort of places where you have
robot you know robotic refrigerators and
frigerators that talk to the internet or
replenish the milk when it's gone and
technology companies for a long time
have tried to resuscitate it microsoft
famously has a home of the future which
it rolls out i think every year so every
couple of years trying to sell us on the
notion that all of our gadgets will talk
to each other in the future and it's
always sort of failed it's never caught
on despite repeated attempts by these
large companies and if you ask them
they'll tell you it's because the
technology wasn't ready yet and if you
ask consumers they'll say something on
lines of i don't see the point in having
an internet-enabled refrigerator well in
the last couple years the notion of
smarter cities has come back with a
vengeance thanks to large part to IBM
and it's smarter planet campaign and if
you've watched a football game or open
to magazine in the last two years you've
seen elements of this campaign and this
time around smarter cities is defined
Hmong as a new definition it's this
vision that with falling computer prices
and his chips get smaller it'll be
affordable enough to thread billions of
transistors trillions
probably around the world in in our
clothes and our buildings everything
else and they'll generate data which
will be wirelessly collected and will be
harvested and put on ever more powerful
computers and those will be run
analytical engines and in the end what
you end up with is something like the
SimCity game we actually saw earlier in
the Netherlands which will be sort of a
living dashboard that you can sort of
tweak your city and as an aside I can't
believe that we ever I don't think we'll
ride ever imagine that sim city would
sort of be the defining interface to
cities for its time but it's really
captured people's visions in that regard
and the point of doing this is that you
could basically see how a city function
you would have sort of a real-time
report card on traffic and water and
power and why would you need this
because you could use it to basically
sort of turn the lights off when no
one's using them turn down the
thermostat and what's the point of that
well it's boring level its costs you
could sell it to someone as you're
saving money if you do that but not but
you can't really capture the imagination
of governments or their voters of you to
sell it is that it's cheaper you need a
grand or narrative you need to be able
to save the world and that in this case
that rationale is climate change its
sustainability we can use energy
efficiency to halt the effects of
climate change that's what people are
willing to invest in and that's what
this campaign is for but perhaps IBM's
interest in a smarter planet has less to
do with saving the world ultimately then
it does with reaching governments
because it's really Sutton once said
about banks that's where the money is
since the recession two years ago IBM's
revenues have been mostly flat and its
fastest growing growth categories are
governments emerging market sales and
business analytics all three of which
are embedded in smarter planet campaign
and should be no surprise that you know
its success in sort of mindless to spawn
copycats one is a hewlett-packard sense
central nervous system for the earth
which uses sort of the same story and
sane so rational and the irony of is
their first customer for this sort of
sensor he's holding there is shale oil
which intends to use their technology to
help it drill for new oil on shore so
you can sort of see that there's cracks
in the narrative there they're going
here and others have gotten into this
google Silver Spring are building smart
grids autodesk is actually creating
SimCity like interfaces all of which are
bound the notion on smarter cities but
perhaps the most interesting case i
think as is a assist
which is traditionally the Internet's
plumber they they make the routers and
switches that the rich data flows and
and as it's grown bigger and bigger it's
now something like a 35 billion dollar
company Cisco is on the lookout for
anything which will dump more and more
data onto the internet so it's invested
heavily in video and video conferencing
you've probably seen ads for its
telepresence which is which is as good
as it's cracked up to be in terms of
making you feel like the other person is
there but the promise of an Internet of
Things and of smarter cities promises
torrents of data so they're very much
strongly looking into this and what's
interesting is that you know a few years
ago Cisco never had a consumer product
they bought the flip camera which you
might have seen but now they want to get
into the business of building cities and
and it is um Cisco sign more than a
dozen deals worldwide to actually help
build smarter cities from scratch this
photo was taken at the signing for Saudi
Arabia's six economic cities it's
building from scratch around the country
the first one is a king abdullah
economic city near cows their new
university the man who's smiling in the
back is John Chambers who Cisco CEO who
told me a year ago the Clinton Global
Initiative that you know we were a
plumber and plumbers an honorable
profession but we want to use the
technology we have now that has the
power to change society's and that in
this case is actually what the briefing
inquires you know the economic cities
have been cast as an effort
sustainability to build greener cities
in the desert but really part of the
deal is is that Saudi Arabia has 10
million people under the age of 17 who
are functionally illiterate and have no
job prospects and so cisco has been
explicitly signed on board to help
create a Saudi Silicon Valley a silicon
Wadi if you will and that's sort of you
know brief that once again goes beyond
simple sustainability the seated man in
front is women L Frank who's Cisco's
point man he's a chief globalization
officer he's the one who's really gotten
into the whole smarter cities thing is
one is one in charge of signing its
deals in India western China the Saudi
Arabian Persian Gulf and Portugal and in
Korea and this is the one I want to talk
to talk about first I have three sort of
smarter cities they're worth discussion
today this is new song dough the years
to note its years of construction not
its lifespan new song dough new song
dough is the most expensive privately
developed building project in history as
a price tag i think somewhere between 35
and 40 billion dollars right now it is
the size of downtown boston it is as
dense as manhattan and it's rising
unreclaimed mudflat off the coast of
korea south of south of the Seoul
Incheon Airport which is connected in
that bridge you see in the background
that's 12 kilometers long that cost a
billion dollars on its own now seeing
through one lens new song dough is one
of the greenest cities in the world the
entire urban developing you see there is
LEED certified it's being built with
super energy efficient materials because
it's being built from scratch so you can
sort of use the best of anything you
like it's got the best of new materials
from 3m new technologies from from from
united technologies it's going to be
reclaiming its wastewater it's going to
be burning its solid waste for it safely
for electricity all of which sort of
leads to sorry few more slides of it
this is actually the Stillwell's taking
a year ago that's at central park that's
coming in the tallest tower in korea
view of some landscape but this is the
sort of projected savings that they hope
to do through its actual sustainability
measures which is basically what third
of the carbon emissions of a similar
city its size so no new song dough is
i've mentioned in my book and many
others have mentioned it is a potential
prototype for how you build a greener
city now on top of this cisco has been
brought in to start applying sensors to
buildings telepresence screens in every
apartment a whole control room for the
master city to sort of guide traffic and
water use and in the process it'll sell
you services at home like you know if
you want to book a tee time at the Jack
Nicholas designed golf course that's on
site or you know we're participate in
the class at the International School
all these sorts of things that can sell
to you 11 service they seriously
suggested by the chief globalization
officer is that it might analyze your
toilet might analyze the contents of
your daily constitutional and offer
nutritional advice so you know they're
thinking ahead and of course it will
sell you these services is sort of a
prepackaged prepackaged thing now that's
the sort of future they envisioned for
this but you know if you'd like to see
where their vision of a smarter City can
go wrong or see where it gone wrong in
the first place you can walk a block
from the tower over to this building
which is a known as tomorrow City and
upstairs sort of kept out of sight by
the developers because then actually
this is owned by the city of Incheon is
sort of a sort of a monument a graveyard
of sort of the failed smart city
prototypes of yesterday built by LG one
of Korea's largest conglomerates and
it's exactly the sort of things that we
sort of discarded 15 years ago sort of
bad interactive television and and out
sort of virtual closets that pick out
objects for you to wear things the
things that you know as visitors it from
America would sort of look at and be
like this is totally not how it worked
out in the end why were you guys trying
to bring this along and it didn't work
out here either um and I think the sort
of speaks to there's a flip side to the
story of Songdo which let to get into
now beyond being a purely green city of
tomorrow on a potential prototype new
song dude was never designed to be a
green city news and some does roots lie
in the asian financial crisis of 1997
1998 when basically korea needed a 58
billion dollar bailout from the IMF and
the IMF said sure but there are
conditions and those conditions included
opening up the country to foreign direct
investment which had never done a great
job at so the Koreans aside well the
easiest way to do that is to actually
sort of build a city for foreigners and
so I'm sooo Songdo is not a Korean city
it is a western city floating off the
coast of Korea designed for
multinationals will set up its offices
there and bring in its people and sort
of it's basically it's a spirit catcher
it's designed to capture the money and
knowledge of these sort of Western
companies and the green aspects to it
were added function effectively in 2006
five years after it was planned and
after construction already began and why
as the developers would tell you they
were having difficulty attracting
multinationals and sustainability had
become such a powerful narrative they
sort of incorporating the elements
because they could they had this
template but basically it was a selling
proposition now it's also always meant
to be a smart city a you city as the
Koreans called ubiquitous city but you
know but the roots of that go beyond go
or go back before the sort of
sustainability narrative popped up in
2006 the Koreans Evans trying to build
ubiquitous cities since 1998 1999 when
they were looking for a future for their
own sort of Silicon Valley again it was
not rooted and sustainability their
smart cities were meant to be sort of an
economic weapon against the Chinese and
against anyone else so again it's it
there the issues go beyond it what's
changed is what's changes the narrative
and when these two
the narrative of sustainability is
powerful narrative and the spirit
catching of Western money and expertise
are what animates the most ambitious
sort of eco-city to date Masdar out in
the desert of Abu Dhabi unlike Songdo
Masdar is a green city with smart city
elements Tom go is sort of the other way
around but in terms of cynicism sand so
one of the talks in there it's really
sort of hard to outdo Masdar the zero
carbon city designed by sir norman
foster Lord Norman Foster is 20 miles
outside of Abu Dhabi reachable only by
car even though gasoline combustion
vehicles are forbidden within this city
of city was being built by the world's
highest per capita energy usage country
in the world the world of the country
with the seventh largest oil reserves
and basically at the center of it is is
mist which is this you know the Masdar
Institute of Science and Technology
which is a science park designed to
attract GE and a whole raft of other
blue-chip multinationals to put into
researchers to basically again sort of
captured Western expertise and sort of
build a technology institute off of
which it can then sell those
technologies to other countries it's
it's about economics it's ultimately not
about sustainability and this you know
the sort of ties into the fact that you
know this is also we're talking about a
country here whose other highlights
merges is a Ferrari theme park that's
under construction and a Formula One
race track with a mega yacht marina in
the middle of it and so it's hard to
imagine that they suddenly developed a
massive ecological consciousness it's
hard to overlook the sort of the
cynicism their master embodies yet
another trend you know seen in smart
cities around the world which is the
notion that the city itself is the
experiment and that the residents are
the people who are spending
experimenting upon themselves they are
the researchers and their the test
subjects and this is sort of seen as a
good thing or sort of part of a
ecological elite you know that but it
also raises unsettling issues the New
York Times and a cover story review of
Masdar raised them last week and asking
the question whether it ever could be a
real city with sort of organic urbanism
involved it sort of interesting another
trait that Songdo and mast our share is
that they are effectively walled cities
when it comes to sustainability Masdar
quite literally there's a wall around it
I'm Songdo figuratively its ecological
technologies and smart
his ends of the property line if amazed
if you read about Songdo you get the
idea that it's being built in this
virgin mud flat and there's nothing
around it for miles but when you go to
it you can see the developers have
literally built up to the property line
in anticipation of what's to come and so
basically sort of sprawl is sort of
surrounded on all sides it sort of
speaks to perhaps the futility of trying
to build the sort of perfect ecological
City and Cisco isn't signed deals with
in chi on the city that owns Songdo to
try to expand it from there but for now
it's sort of isolated and I want to stop
for just a second here to make a point
about cynicism which is sort of the core
of my speech I don't believe and I've
never come across reporting and I've
never spoken anyone I've never had any
reason to believe that the developers of
cities such as these may be the
exception of Masdar and companies like
Cisco and IBM believe that they'll fail
or believe that this isn't good for the
planet they do believe that smart cities
can be good for fighting climate change
and there are plenty of case studies to
show this it's just that they think they
can make a lot of money while doing it
but there's something though the greater
complication i think involved in this is
that when you basically do as Jimmy
Carter once said you know 30 years ago
that climate change peak oil they're
sort of entwined is the moral equivalent
of war well when you really start to
believe that as a society the moral
equivalent of war gives way to the moral
equivalent of an military industrial
complex companies that sort of rise up
to take advantage of this and start
applying their own logic and their own
narrative on this and in this case it's
technology companies who believe they
hold the keys to this and so the
implication and what happens over time
is is you invite them to take a seat at
the table in plotting urbanism and they
begin trying to adapt or think of cities
as software they try to make urbanism
and cities behave like software to make
them faster more efficient perfectly
replicable and increasing returns to
scale they want to build the perfect
sustainable city and they want to be
able to roll it out faster and faster on
a global scale and you can see this
logic the perfect example really is in
my next example which is planet valley
which is the creation of a startup
called living planet which is been
founded by a former microsoft exec now
living planets ideas are too full one
they want to overhaul the global
construction industry which is
incredibly wasteful and sort of hand
craft and they basically want to make it
more
like just in time lean manufacturing
like Toyota or like Boeing or any of
those and but the more ambitious piece
even is there sort of core piece of code
an urban operating system a sort of core
piece of software that will tie it all
together they'll own it they will own it
and they will create a sort of model
where they'll invite in partners
software companies including Cisco which
is participant in this and management
companies things like that who create
their own apps to run water power
traffic and sell you things and so
essentially what you end up with and
their model is a city that behaves a lot
like your iPhone in which case royalties
are being paid to them because they only
own the platform they own the operating
system and governments we paying them as
well you know the example of that or
their test subject is a planet Valley
and sir this is example of sort of their
whole business model and you know being
built right now outside of Portugal is
there sort of is their test case planet
Valley which is you know it's expecting
what is complete we'll have a population
of 150,000 people it's being built on
the hillsides outside Porto almost all
the residents they conceive will be
employees of themselves or of their
partners it's a company town effectively
and they'll all be working on the
innovations they hope to export to
cities of being built from scratch in
China India and so on and so once again
the city itself is the experiment and as
they can see that it's a city that lives
in the cloud it's essentially they
imagine decommissioning buildings like
you decommission a server their IT would
define the urbanism um and while the
impetus of course to build these cities
they're very well versed the founders of
this and sort of the the issues that
have come up before the challenge of
urbanization mass migration
sustainability all of that it has not
escaped their attention that will do
wonders for your property values and for
the you know the net worth of your
undeveloped land so while it's an open
question that any of living planet
cities get built it is a start-up after
all cisco is pursuing almost the similar
model it's imagining software stacks and
cloud computing managing its cities you
know and song those developers
themselves gale international is the
name of the company they're based here
in Manhattan and kpf computers and Fox
the architects they've sort of they're
seeing it the same way right now k PF's
architects are trying to reverse
engineer the thousands and thousands of
decision
and process steps that went into
designing and building new song they
want to figure out the formula for how
they arrived at a city built from
scratch and so on I was actually a nice
city it is it is an amalgam of the best
western cities which sounds like Dubai
when you see heater described like the
best of Paris Savannah New York but
basically means they took the grid of
New York and the pocket parks of
Savannah and they've sort of layered in
a complex urbanism that doesn't try to
do too much but now they're trying to
basically sort of learn from their learn
from that process so they can speed it
up Stan Gail wants to build not another
new city he wants to build 20 new cities
across China and he wants to build the
next one in seven and a half years not
15 and wants to build the one after that
in five years and eventually he thinks
he can get down the infrastructure to 36
months and he can do this because he's
brought in cisco to help him automate it
and his architects and the same
consortium to sort of build these cities
across China and so again it's the logic
of software Moore's law everything's
going to move faster it's going to get
cheaper every 18 months and we can sort
of accelerate urbanism to the pace of
the technology that's going to save us
all the the first sequel to Songdo was
going to be built outside changsha in
western China was Maisie Lake the lake
in fact was faith they were going to
flood it replace it i think in a lake at
one time but that project has been
effectively canceled due to the vagaries
of the chinese real estate market and
Chinese politics I think they
effectively asked for too much dealing
with them but they're trying again at
the moment they are there got to submit
a proposal to the government of
Chongqing which is the fastest growing
city on earth foreign policy just wrote
a great piece about this chong ching is
that technically municipality of 32
million people spread across the size of
New Jersey but the urban core is about 6
million people and it's growing 300,000
people a year which is the equivalent of
bolting on Pittsburgh to your city year
after year after year so they're going
to basically try to build the gleaming
portion of it the smart city that stands
as an example to that you know will I
succeed I'm quite possible you could
actually get it build so in a sort of
sum up the notion of crusade or cynicism
is the title of this talk I mean in some
sense the answer is both I mean we the
creators of these cities in the
technologists do believe this is a
a actual weapon they can be using
against climate change but the question
I think that we have to ask as voters as
citizens in there is basically sort of
who controls the data that they're going
to generate from this and there's
already been debates that come out of
this about you know of cities basically
selling off their citizens aggregate
data to corporations and also sort of
basically sort of you know forcing our
cities to develop in the sort of logic
and scale of software of how quickly we
can build these I don't know there's
interesting applications and I don't
have any answers to that but it is
fascinating that the notion of a smarter
City is basically to think of a city in
terms of not in terms of traditional
urbanism the Jane Jacobs approach of
building a functional city for people
but building really a sort of functional
city that you can then roll out
endlessly and perfect as you go so thank
you very much that's why book coming out
well well this is loading just just a
few words of introduction I was booked
mr. fuller we said think global act
local and it's one of the things I'll
make reference to in some of the
projects i want to show and so i'll
start with a bit of a global perspective
leading to the relevance of the built
environment on different scales and
there is certainly a lot to be said
about the contribution of the build
environment to our climate problems I
think that's pretty much established at
this point and I really want to focus on
energy and how wind integration or the
use of natural resources can help us to
probably help to solve these problems
and so I'd like to just start off with
this and this is from the national
Geographics milestone in our history in
2008 with half the human population
living in urban centers so obviously
there is various effects that come with
that and if we now look at the energy
consumption by sector in the last set of
decades from 52 to 10 we see a
significant contribution of the building
sector which is considered in the
developed world to take about fifty
percent of our energy consumption and
then we have about a quarter from the
industry but a quarter flow of
transportation if you look at this from
an architectural standpoint we're also
involved in designing transportation by
being part of the urban planning we
certainly draw from the industry by
specifying products materials all the
things we use in our building so it's
not quite clear where we are and it
certainly isn't quite clear what it
means to consume energy because there's
many forms of energy so if we look at
the world electricity generation just
like to speak about that and focus on
this for a second by fuel we certainly
see a massive increase according to our
use
and we have various energy resources to
make that happen now if we look at
electricity generation related to co2
emissions from fossil fuel sources we
see a significant contribution primarily
based on coal combustion which is here
in the US the the leading source for the
generation of electricity now however is
that to do with buildings well it has a
lot to do with buildings because if we
look at the apologize some nodes went
missing here I think there were font
issues this is basically by the American
agency information agency for energy and
VOE and you see the relevance of the
building factor with having a
seventy-six percent share in this so
obviously we as architects participate
in this discussion to a large degree
talking about different scales I'd like
to briefly touch on the reaction that we
see if we propose the use of these kinds
of technologies which is wind turbines
in particular large scale turbines and
this is a project that touches on
various scales and has a lot to do not
only with the city but how we
participate as consumers within a
community and so this is the proposal
and you probably heard the news a couple
of month ago that it's going ahead the
design for the first offshore wind farm
in the u.s. in Cape Cod and this is the
proposal that was just signed off on and
the Boston society of Architects in
response to a huge amount of protest was
challenging this and was questioning
designers from all over the world to
answer the question how do we deal with
this right and it's not just a social
economical problem because certain
people on their private beaches really
don't like this view it's also you know
ordinary people not only heavy
industrial that have the money and the
lawyers to defend this but it's pretty
much everybody in the community that is
producing this right the goal is to
generate 70 75 percent of clean and
renewable energy for the community this
is what they get so the question is what
do you do with that BSA asks us to
to make this a different experience
right could be a water park would be
educational could be fantastic as an
environment to learn to live with this
and we won that competition by basically
saying guess what it's not good enough
we we need to do something very
different here and we basically
redesigned the entire brief in three
distinct steps so the first was just
look at what we have why do we need all
this in the first place then we started
to really find the parameters by looking
at various studies that were done in
Germany and Denmark on community
upgrades and how we could use
contemporary technologies to minimize
energy conjunction then we looked at
more efficient technologies for the use
in exchange the winter event types
according to what are available then and
then we said this is really not just a
local political problem this is a
national problem and obviously if the
states as a whole don't change the
attitudes then that is a bit of a
problem too so can we do something to
bring us to a national level and I don't
really want to go into too much detail
but the point on the studies that we
found was that we find a lot of
household equipment from 60 70 s 80s and
compared to contemporary devices those
are just not very efficient so upgrading
an average community could significantly
help to change the way that community
consumes and that would really attached
to every single household and the
individual that lives there leading to
potentially average fifty fifty two
percent savings in energy consumption
and then respectively co2 emissions so
then exchanging the turbines to a more
powerful device that helped us to
further reduce the required turbines and
summing up we found that we can really
significantly reduce energy consumption
and then respectively the turbines that
are needed to generate the electricity
for that community ending up with 50 now
that's obviously a very beautiful number
when you think of the national scale and
so the next step was done in designing
this wind farm to say can we do this in
a way that people take pride and
participating in this rather than being
fearful and rejected and this is the
plan of this wind farm and you see it
here from the air
obviously much more compact and it's
starting to be what we call the energy
island so rather than seeing this as a
power plant that no one really likes we
wanted this to make an exciting
environment for people to go to the next
step then looking at the turbines was to
understand these structures are
incredibly elaborate they take
incredible wind loads and can we do
something to generate the park with
minimal means and by basically reducing
embodied energy consumption by adding
very very little to the elaborate
structures that are ready and this is
what we had it it's a very spider web
delicate suspension system that works
structurally in a way that it also
represents the political power behind
this it's a it's a very delicate system
in many ways but it essentially means
that if one of the turbines representing
one of the state's doesn't hold up
doesn't contribute doesn't exist then
the whole system becomes weak and
eventually fails so it's a structured
interpretation of a political idea now
then we said in this wind park we would
like to have every state to participate
on what we call the deck section which
is essentially an outside pavilion where
they could talk about the initiatives
that could change throughout the seasons
could make it a very exciting
environment that is ever-changing and
then obviously it would be also a pretty
embarrassing spot to have a blank
pavilion because we're not doing
anything now this is main that they're
doing pretty good so we picked them well
so this is the the idea where you would
really have some sort of export
arrangement representing these different
states and just giving you a bit of an
idea where we envisioned this to be what
we call the e50 arena which is a
environment for sports activities all
sorts of cultural activities that could
be sports competitions there could be
concerts all sorts of cultural events
because one of the biggest fears there
are is to threaten the tourism in the
state which is one of the major sources
of income
community so then we started to add
buildings that would house all the
required functions technological
functions programmatic functions so
there could be cafes exhibition spaces
that could be all the technical
equipment that would negotiate that ring
park as you see here as a diagram with
that suspended portion and the building
would negotiate with the water level it
would also allow for water access and
activities on these different levels and
this is what it would look like from the
water and then we edit more functions to
second building where we said isn't it a
nice opportunity to I love for different
forms of access but to also allow for
different programmatic needs to be
accommodated for and eventually bring
people from the community so they could
really learn to live with these kinds of
technologies this is what we call the
multi-purpose Piazza I could house all
sorts of different events hopefully
celebrating the reduced amount of
turbines and the increased efficiency in
the community and then also bring in
people of different ages looking at this
edition which would be a platform for
public use for instance driving schools
surfing schools etc so again bring in
the community into this or making it a
public pool during the summer so this is
where we started with 130 large-scale
turbines basically placed entirely on
engineering and financial concerns and
this is what we ended up with and really
starting to address the community the
city environment behind this so this is
a comparison between an animation that
cable is still putting forward and this
is the comparison so the wind for much
more remote from the coast much more a
destination point and then certainly a
very different programmatic idea behind
all this and we were hoping that that
would be appreciated by all inhabitants
of the bank
so that little guy there and so again
this is what we started with and this is
what we ended up with so that's looking
at the community engagement related to
these technologies and how you know you
can really engage every single one in
understanding that you know whatever we
do it has consequences and sometimes we
don't like them going into research I'd
like to very briefly introduce a couple
of projects and this is really more to
be seen as a string of thoughts it's
impossible to explain all this in a few
minutes but so I'll just touch on a
couple of things one is that we really
need and most of the people that have
spoken already represented also an
interdisciplinary working load and I'm
collaborating with aerospace engineer
now that is not a typically common
combination of disciplines but we're
having a really great time in learning
from another how we can make buildings
more efficient or for him to learn about
buildings at all and this is a project
episode involved with that is doing a
couple of things for us and what we're
trying to understand is if we look at
buildings how can we start to manipulate
an airflow around the building for
various reasons and I just want to show
the principles behind this typically we
live with certain wind loads for
instance we design the structure
accordingly here we go what we started
to do is set up an experiment you see
the base configuration on the top left
where we assume certain wind direction
we've chosen elliptical footprint to
understand pretty distinct pressure
differentials around the building and
then we actuated what we call flow
resistance devices this could be wind
turbine screens all sorts of other
things and we started to see that we can
start to manipulate the air flow around
the building so we could literally flip
the profile so the building would
interact with the environment in a very
different way and then initiating the
turban on the other side seeing an
increase and who's not used to this this
is what's called CFD plots computer
fluid dynamics it's a simulation process
where you can simulate air flow pressure
velocity etc and you know there's low
pressure blue
in rent is high pressure you see when we
activate two of those a lot of those
conditions change very drastically so
then going into what we do is architects
speculative but designing a typical plan
and then backing off a little and
diagramming this in a way that we could
understand the science behind it so this
is what happens in terms of rett what we
call exfiltration it's relieving air
what building so we're leaving the
building versus infiltration the blue
ones which is pushing into the building
this has to do with natural ventilation
we're still kind of fighting for
projects in the u.s. to really
acknowledge that that works it's a
little odd but it's typically you know
like here we are in the space and it's
actually a little cold and it's a little
odd that we have all these advanced
technologies we're thinking of entire
smart cities yet we still have to get
the grip on controlling environments and
buildings so if we look at this you can
start to see what happens we can control
enhance natural ventilation for this
high-rise which is fairly unusual we can
also think of then amending established
apologies not only in the building
structure but for instance in
redesigning facade components which if
you want to do that are typically double
layered excessive use of materials very
expensive too we can understand the
impact on natural ventilation modes we
can understand the impact on reduced
stress loads in the structure which also
helps to save materials and we
understand the different means of
controlling the environment outside and
inside the building obviously we have a
lot of existing buildings and the
question is we not want to design all of
them because they will be sticking
around for a while so is there anything
we can do to make use of these
structures and so we were trying to do
is understand a how does the building
participate what kind of conditions to
be fined and this is from colleagues and
Melbourne that looked at these kinds of
buildings in a computer fluid dynamic
environment and they find these hotspots
makes a lot of sense the a accumulates
in front of the bill
it shoots around the corners and that's
exactly where I'm trying to interfere
with these wings as I call them so you
see the green error and what happens is
you've got these two facials that would
help to compress the air and increase
the capacity of the turbine I'll show in
another example in a second now the
urban environment is highly
unpredictable you have a lot of
turbulence ha's and you don't quite
understand what you can do so that is a
challenge and I'll show you the model
and then this is one of the syracuse
university program buildings that we
occupy where we working on a proposal to
hopefully implement this this is really
a project that's exciting me most
because we're in the middle of realizing
this it's a self-sustaining streetlight
the ideas to develop a streetlight that
works entirely off the energy grid that
can be planted like a tree and that is
entirely self-supporting combines
vertical axis wind turbine low-energy
LEDs and PV and so we're really trying
to get this to the point of
commercialization and we're pretty much
there this is a couple of preliminary
sketches where you see the top and the
lower right shows the principle it's
basically about compressing air in a way
that it increases velocity and pressure
towards the center of this and that
preliminary sketch that shows where the
turbine is located now thinking about
how there could be multiplied according
to the consumption so it goes back to
the ideas of the wind farm generate as
much as you need not necessarily more
and this is another c of d plot showing
how that principle works again you see
the significant increase going up to the
highest scale and that provides
increased velocity and pressure and the
center that's where the turbine is and
we see an increase of that efficiency up
to three hundred percent it also helps
to reduce the startup time of the
turbine which means that it kicks in
much earlier with low winds then we
obviously need to find means of storing
that energy that we generate during the
to then consume it at night and
hopefully if there is a surplus in urban
areas to then feed into the grid if we
can so we've been through various steps
looking at all these different
components and developing them to the
degree that we can really start the
prototyping now we're looking at wind
canal testing at one of our research
partners at Clarkson University and
we're moving into the digital
fabrication where we translate computer
fluid dynamic optimization for all CDs
in design models that can help us to
really develop the product this is some
engineering studies for the geometry
optimization so the relation of casework
and turbine going back into the design
process and this is the designers of
currently stands that we are now working
towards commercialization building the
prototype and this is it i just wanted
to show a 30 second sequence and then
i'm going to be wrapping up could you
start that or should i start that from
here
oh I'm recording Oh what oh I'm
recording oh oh I'm recording what yeah
we got excited so we're really at a
point where we have the confirmation and
now take this a step further and I want
to close with two things one is showing
how this could be implemented in a
certainly rural environment but we're
working with an industry partner that's
working and we have the patent on this
but they are working with the
provisional patent on a turbine that
works with turbulent flow in environment
like a city where you have a lot of
different conditions at different times
so that would hopefully allow us to
really bring this on to the city
environment as well just two quick
things in terms of architecture can we
now use this and the intention was from
the start to test something on a fairly
small scale to then bring it into the
building environment and this is the
design for a residence or I call the
turbine house and that would work really
with the same kind of principles and so
that would then determine the design of
the entire structure see how that's
implemented at the top of the building
you've got a big pergola which is using
solar heat exchangers and PV panels to
run the building as much as the turbine
does for the energy supply typical
section of the middle piece an
understanding that we want to get we
don't want to mimic I totally agree that
we can't mimic but we can learn from
nature certainly and then the question
can we make environmentally efficient
architecture more desirable or can we
find new topologies that really reflect
the technical innovation that's a
narrative in there and then finishing
with the flux Tower which again is an
idea to translate the early
is of multiplying the effects into
high-rise structures learning from
controlling airflow around the building
is what i call the energy shield which
work out to protect the actual skin
where it reflects understanding the
performance impact of significantly
reduced suction on the back of the
building which is as significant as
pushes you get in the front going
through an optimization process to
design this building and then
understanding the very different design
that comes out of that process compared
to conventional building topologies so
then multiplying that effect that you
saw in the sectional diagram the diagram
in the middle and take is also in the
plan so you've got decentralized course
that helped to also direct the air flow
to the center where the turbines are
located thinking of modules in terms of
an optimized construction and evaluation
process and then again understanding
this in an urban context and the
difference to conventional building
topologies thank you very much
thank you
well saskia put me into this session and
I feel like a spoiler but sometimes it's
good to bring you back to some sort of
sense of reality i loved what i saw and
greg lindsay and particularly made it
easy for me to be set up i will have
some comments i want to start with two
assertions and say that one despite
great strides to understand the earth's
natural process and managing the growth
of cities where the rich or poor has
become utterly divorced from recognizing
the great destructive power of normal
extreme events that are an integral part
of the earth inner workings this in my
mind is the expression of a clash of two
things the time horizons human time
horizon vs let's call it geological time
horizons and to the objectives of men to
seek concentration of power in cities
are the best symbol of concentration of
power while nature on the other hand
seeks dispersive entropy it wants to
equalize things road mountain
and to the growth of cities proceeds
largely in denial of man-made
accelerated climate change especially of
hastened sea-level rise and this denial
puts many coastal cities at an advanced
risk and dooming summed become
unsustainable well sometimes we can
learn from history even so we really
seem to do it but before I go there let
me first outline what I think are some
of the consequences from those two
premises natural disasters involving
major cities are nasty price because
there are many more ever larger and more
vulnerable cities in often precarious
locations and two in this century there
is a finite chance at a single natural
disaster that costs more than a million
fatalities or losses in excess of one
trillion dollars and I say or because
the fatalities will occur of course in
the poor developing cities and the
trillions will be developed cities in
both our address but not necessarily
from the same event
learning from history I'm asking where's
Alexandria so let's take a plunge into
history here it is this is Cleopatra
Palace Temple of Isis submerged in 30
feet of water and if you can read it on
the upper right the submersion rate is
about 5 millimeters per year that's less
than half the thickness of my finger
every year but it adds up to quite some
impact and so again we can't blame
Cleopatra for not knowing about that but
there is no excuse today for not knowing
we have pretty much most of the facts
that we need relatively at our
fingertips notwithstanding all the great
uncertainties in probabilities that we
have talked earlier today
well this city is not 2,000 years old
it's a little bit older than 200 years
and we see here the beginning of a
similar process the submergence rate is
right now about the same as politics
Andrea which was also a delta the Nile
Delta this is the Mississippi Delta all
Delta's have the property that they
compact the sediment so they sink
naturally for geologic reasons in
addition of course we put sea level rise
on top of it so those two will
accelerate in the future while the
geological compaction pretty much stays
constant we will accelerate sea level
rise again we can't blame the French
when they start at New Orleans and they
were smart enough to put it on the crest
of the natural levees that the
Mississippi River built on its own so
the old French forts and all that in the
old French city are at a relatively safe
place but then cities expand into places
where they shouldn't we have the
knowledge now that it shouldn't but do
we use it
well back home what does this mean here
in New York as part of the mayor's
effort to look at climate change we had
an NPC is analogy to the IPCC not the
International that the New York panel on
climate change and we were charged to
look at what happens to York City while
you see here three colors red yellow and
we actually tells you that this is the
extent of the so-called Hannity of blood
or one percent and yoli probability how
it will extend with sea level rise in
this place is shown to be two and four
meters two and four feet and yeah we
already have currently a risk exposure
for 100 years to one but it will get
worse with time now New York City unlike
most of New Orleans has the advantage
that many places including this building
are way above sea level so we would lose
something on the frenches and could
retreat and make Manhattan even denser
than it is what's the big problem well
the big problem is colored line subway
system in the back lines that are other
failed commuting systems and Amtrak and
their city below the city there are way
below the sea level already so when you
race
wrenches to eventually encroach on all
the entrances that are normally supposed
to be dry whether you go into the subway
or whether you walk on the pedestrian
walk over the grits where you hear the
subpoena me when you flood some of those
we calculated its title calculations it
takes about 40 to 50 minutes the subway
system
now we worked with the MDA to figure out
how long it would take to bring the
system back remember there is equipment
in there that would get submerged into
salt water for which no replacement
sixes taken apart cleaner reassemble
estimates range from three weeks to two
years depending on details the gun
certainly
well some people have said oops that's
not very gross this is for instance what
subway tunnels and remember they go
under the you can't just suck it out you
have to have submersible pumps and all
that sort of thing so when you get into
the nitty-gritty how you would deal with
that so you this problem you're really
in our time to figure out how to just
logistically do it not to speak of
technical details
now many people have said okay so let's
fill some barriers you need at least
three perhaps four four because if you
don't build this one this whole part of
brooklyn is still exposed at strategic
points and barrier off your city is that
sustainable it is my very personal
notion that it is not essentially we are
setting ourselves up for a situation
along your leads where we build a
defense system it has a finite lifetime
it needs a lot of maintenance it has to
grow with sea level rise and in the
meanwhile you feel safe behind that
system and then comes the low
probability extreme event and wipes you
out and you are totally unprepared for
that event behind your supposedly
functional defenses so I'm not excluding
the possibility that temporarily we may
have some barriers one of the New York
engineering firms made a conceptual
drawing they may have a temporary role
but as sea level keeps rising there's a
problem and the problem is essentially
not in New York it's up in Greenland and
so far we have been dealing with the sea
level rise simply from the warming of
the
oceans and the water of the oceans
expense it once but on top of it there
are curves here they'll tell you how
much heat of globally the sea level will
rise if we meant goes under the unfair
influence on certain temperatures in
which we believe we can stabilize the
atmosphere plus 2 degrees of 135 in an
hour a above the current average level
depending on that you have these
additional sea level rise growth and
that is just on the Arctic are this is
just Greenland there will be Antarctica
we don't the climate scientists that is
don't have yet a good handle on what
Antarctica will do all so I'm simply
saying that if you built a defense
system and you don't have an exit
strategy you are actually in trouble
it's a little bit like declaring war to
nature and you have not an exit strategy
how to get out of there boy
now to come back to the global situation
here we have as of January of this year
the cities around the world with more
than eight million oh it's not really
cities it's sort of a mixture of urban
agglomeration however that define is
defined you get a different list of who
is in and who is out here but we see of
course all that these are just the
cities of which all are located on costs
so they will have to deal with sea level
rise not all the millions in each city
but a subset of their population within
each city and then we have planned
cities where do we plan them in the
water as if sea level rise would not
exist now I'm not saying they couldn't
last hundred years old by herbs 200
years but are we really planning cities
we have seen this picture before and
gret reminded us that to see the other
monthly
I took from his same paper okay and on
the right I put sea level rise
earthquakes and urban floods and
mudslides just as some of the hazards to
which they are exposed to various
degrees because of time I will
accelerate this slide shows three income
groups and the growth of cities between
1960 and 2000 in each of those three
income groups what we see is the
horrendous rise of low-income cities of
between three and eight and above eight
million as compared to the relatively
stagnant growth in the high-income
cities when we look at another graph
between 1950s in two thousand this is
now the population their lifts in the 50
largest cities in the world and then a
subset which ones are are exposed to
earthquake hazards and within that group
which 1i in developing countries and we
see that the total increase in the
population was or three times over that
period in those cities 50 largest cities
the earthquake threatened wants is
growing by seven times and those
that are in that yellow part but are in
developing countries grew by ten times
so what this means is we are adding
constantly at an excessive right
vulnerable cities this is a gruesome
statistic where earthquake magnitude on
the right and the death on the top is
being plotted here's Heidi here's Tom
Shawn this was in 76 officially 240,000
fatalities in officially maybe more than
half a million and we all know Heidi
just a few years so what does this mean
in terms of this growth of cities you
can make a plot in which you plot the
cumulative number of fatal earthquakes
against the fatalities then you get this
gruesome plot and you see that there are
a couple of world several above hundred
thousand and it essentially tells you
since we are adding these multi-million
population cities to it it is quite
likely that within this 100-year period
this was from 1997 we will fill out this
training out there with an unpleasant
target of one to two events with a
million people at one stroke this is the
list of the 25 largest urban
agglomerations of this year again with
the hazards in these three patterns and
if you look at them you know they are
anywhere from thirty four million tokyo
and tokyo is exposed to all of these
various hazards to Lagos being
one of the fastest growing city arm and
many a many of them as we have seen from
Mumbai which would be here i'll have of
course real problems not to react just
to those possibilities but to planning
and forward sense so what can we do and
i hope to wrap this up but before I if
you even a formula risk someone
mentioned earlier is the probability x
its consequence well that's the
probability of the hazard and that's the
consequence but risk if you want to take
a measure of risk let's say the last
dollar losses it's simply a probability
where you sum up over the whole region
of interest let's say all parts of New
York City all parts of United Arab
Emirates and locally you sum up over a
product the hazard times the assets that
are exposed to the hazard times the
vulnerability of those assets now we can
reduce the hazard for instance from
climate change sea level rise by
mitigation by not admitting is many
greenhouse gases but there are other
ways to reduce the rest we can have no
assets exposed well that's what's
happening in the art and Arctic are so
that's not working very well we still
want to have assets so when we look now
at the combination of hazards and assets
it's a matter of where we place them
that means land use planning and zoning
considered placement of new assets
relocation of essential assets levees
and dams with a question mark because
their sustainability is not clear they
are the equity
who is inside and outside the protected
areas who is on the bad soil in the
goodman you can't look at another
combination not the assets and hazards
but now we look at the assets and
vulnerability that means good
engineering means construction quality
control codes and code enforcement
retrofitting raising assets in place
sometimes reinforcing levees and maybe
increasing the capacity of pump station
but the simplest thing would be with
using vulnerability varied using poverty
that would be the most effective risk
reduction now set the simplest and you
know it's probably the most difficult
Millennium Goals you say so to cure or
not to cure or I modify that to cure and
how to cure then that is the question we
have the option to remain oblivious to
the processes of nature and let her do
her grandma education lemme kill and
destroy that is unfortunately by and
large with some exceptions the current
state of affairs on a global scale the
most devastating effects in the poorest
and least developed nations and cities
within you go from port-au-prince in
Haiti to an effluent country and yet a
poor city like New Orleans was important
to him or we initiate and pursue strikes
in a systematic global movement of
disaster risk of error urban planning
gross or in Europe towards achieving
sustainable elbow habitats and we cannot
exclude the basic understanding
scientific understanding how the earth
works when we go ahead and dream up our
cities there are samples
of the past present when some in the
future all we hear about the Netherlands
and they deal with it in various levels
of success I would not say everything to
success there you have scaled back from
your 10 to the minus 4 per year to 10 to
the minus 3 per year acceptance as to
what losses are you now plan for the
levies to be overflow and deal with that
rather than preventing overflow so there
are many ways to go London has James
ester a 2100 project Hamburg I will come
in a second to it st. previous Berg most
of them like Venice are essentially
walls behind your height which you hide
all I have an example where they don't
hide ah there's the c40 for the city's
effort it was originally largely for
mitigating with using emissions I think
they gradually come around that
adaptation is a necessity oh and the sea
40s are expanding it now coats places
like Jakarta and so on we have a plan
here in New York City 2030 and the NPC
see that got to work but that's yet on a
study level it's Nadia an implementation
level so we still have to rally the
political support and the money to do it
resetting of priorities there's the you
name Millennium Development Goals which
has a component about disaster risk
reduction the international strategy for
disaster really now and as a side line
of the Kyoto
sure or was the hyoga framework and so
on there are other things listed here
and I'm closing with this example and
the reason I am closing with it because
it's an effort not hiding behind walls
it's an effort to live with the with the
flood this is the city of Hamburg where
r this part here is protected by levees
and dams but there's a so called harbor
city which is really an assembly of
several hundred year whole old
warehouses where you could drive your
boats in unload it and then roads went
out and delivered the goods to the land
this is being redeveloped but it's being
redeveloped with sea level rise in mind
the way they do it right now it's they
said it at 8 meters above the present
which buys them maybe 200 years and then
they will have to deal with it again so
I'm not saying that this is much better
than levees and dams and barriers but it
is a more organic way to adaptively
recycle our knowledge our assets and do
it on a project-by-project basis rather
than having an entire community agree in
one time on one solution and then defer
down the line a similar community
decision four hundred 200 years are
certainly I find this more encouraging
and for instance more applicable to New
York than building barriers but that of
course is a discussion in the
communities and has to be locally
resolved mitigation using emissions is a
global goal adaptation occurs locally is
a local issue and with that thank you
very much thank you everyone we're going
to have a break now and the next group
of speakers will begin at three-thirty
you